BACKLOG EVERY TWO YEARS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
MEANTIME, OF COURSE, 20 HOUSE
SEATS LEFT IN PLAY.
REPUBLICANS NEED JUST SEVEN OF
THEM TO FLIP THE HOUSE.
WHILE THE RESULTS ARE UNCLEAR
THERE IS ONE THING THAT DOES
REMAIN CLEAR.
THE RED WAVE DID NOT MATERIALIZE
THIS MIDTERM ELECTION SEASON.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMPS FORMER
WHITE HOUSE ADVISOR NAILED THE
ANALYSIS ON "SUNDAY MORNING
FUTURES".
>> THE NUMBER ONE REASON FOR
THAT IS DEMOCRAT MASTERY OF MAIL
AND VALIDATING, VOTE HARVESTING
AND THE MACHINERY OF THE EARLY
VOTE VOTING WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> DISPARITY IS STILL ENORMOUS.
NUMBER THREE IS THE NEED TO WIN
INDEPENDENT VOTERS BY SEIZING ON
WINNING WEDGE ISSUES AND
FIGHTING FOR THEM WITH EVERY
BREATH THAT YOU HAVE.
DEMOCRATS DO THIS, REPUBLICANS
DON'T.
IF THERE IS ANY VOTER IN THIS
PLACE BELIEVE THAT THEY WOULD
IMMEDIATELY SHUT DOWN THE BORDER
CRISIS?
SHUTTING DOWN HEAVEN AND EARTH,
SHUT IT DOWN IF THEY HAD TO SEAL
UP THE BORDER.
NO ONE BELIEVES THAT.
>> A LOT TO UNPACK THEIR.
LET'S START IN NEVADA, FOR
EXAMPLE.
79% OF THE VOTES WERE EARLY
VOTES.
WE HAVE EXPANDED ELECTION
SEASON.
WE GET THEM MORE TIME TO VOTE.
IN SOME PLACES THEY ARE MAILING
IN THEIR VOTES.
NOW WE KNOW REPUBLICANS HAVE
LOST NEVADA AS WELL.
WE ARE WAITING FOR THAT RUNOFF.
IF HERSCHEL WALKER WERE TO WIN,
IF HARRIS WINS AGAIN THE
TIEBREAKER.
>> THIS IS A DISASTER.
A WEEK AFTER THE ELECTION AND WE
ARE STILL TALKING ABOUT IT.
YOU TALK ABOUT LATE EARLY
BALLOTS, YOU PROBABLY HAVE A
PROBLEM, IF THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
BALLOTS CAST ON ELECTION DAY
BEING THE PROBLEM HERE, THAT IS
NOT THE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS, WE ARE STILL
FLOATING, HOLDING ELECTIONS
UNDER THIS PANDEMIC CRISIS MODE
WHERE INSTEAD OF ELECTION DAY,
YOU HAVE ELECTION WEEK OR
ELECTION WEEKS WHICH, OF COURSE,
NOT ONLY DOES IT INVITE REAL,
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE ELECTION,
BUT THEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE NOT ONLY DO YOU INVITE
REAL PROBLEMS WITH INACCURATE
ELECTION, YOU ALSO HAVE
EVERYBODY JUST THINKING THAT THE
GAME IS RIGGED.
>> PERCEPTION IS SOMETIMES MORE
IMPORTANT THAN REALITY TO SOME
PEOPLE.
EVERY BOAT COUNTS, EVERY THOUGH
MATTER.
REPUBLICANS, I THINK THAT THEY
ARE EXACTLY RIGHT WHEN THEY SAY
WE NEED TO GET A HANDLE ON OUR
ELECTION SYSTEMS.
IT'S ONE THING TO COMPLAIN, IT'S
ANOTHER THING IF WE DON'T PLAY
AT ALL.
WE DON'T FIGHT FOR THOSE EARLY
VOTES.
WE DON'T PLAY THE GAMES THAT THE
DEMOCRATS PLAY BECAUSE WE WANT
TO BE SELF-RIGHTEOUS BUT WE KEEP
LOSING BECAUSE WE ARE THAT SELF
RIGHTEOUS.
WE WILL HAVE TO PLAY THE GAME.
>> TO CAUSES.
ONE IS THE TECHNICAL ISSUE OF
HOW ELECTIONS ARE HANDLED.
IF YOU WANT, THE DEMOCRATS WILL
PASS A VOTING RIGHTS ACT THAT
WILL FEDERALIZE HOW STATES ELECT
FEDERAL OFFICES, BUT THAT IS NOT
WHAT REPUBLICANS WANT.
IT IS HARD TO DO THIS WHILE
ADVOCATING AGAINST ANY FEDERAL
LAW THAT WOULD ADVOCATE AGAINST
THOSE ELECTIONS.
WE HAVE TO RECONCILE THIS A
LITTLE BIT.
IF YOU GO BACK TO JUST STRATEGY
AND HOW YOU WIN VOTES, IT IS
HARD FOR ME TO STOMACH RICK
SCOTT POINTING A FINGER AT MITCH
MCCONNELL FOR THE WAY HE
ELABORATED HIS STRATEGY WHICH
WAS TO TALK ABOUT HOW BAD
DEMOCRATS ARE WHEN RICK SCOTT
PUT OUT A TAX PLAN WHEN NO OTHER
REPUBLICAN SUPPORTED THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WERE ABLE TO MESSAGE
BECAUSE RICK SCOTT IS REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IT WAS A REPUBLICAN
TAX PLAN.
MCCONNELL DID NOT HAVE A GOOD
PLAN.
HE CAN ONLY SAY THAT BECAUSE HE
PUT A PLAN OUT THERE THAT
DEMOCRATS USED AGAINST US.
THIS IS MORE ABOUT REPUBLICANS
GETTING ON THE SAME PAGE OR JUST
AS MUCH AS IT IS ABOUT
PENNSYLVANIA OR NEVADA OR
COLORADO DOES THEIR ELECTIONS.
>> SPEAKING OF RICK SCOTT HE WAS
ON "SUNDAY MORNING FUTURES"
EARLIER THIS MORNING.
LET'S TAKE A LESSON.
>> HERE IS MY FOCUS.
WE STILL HAVE TO WIN GEORGIA.
I WILL NOT TAKE ANYTHING OFF THE
TABLE, BUT MY JOB IS TO DO
ANYTHING THAT I CAN HELP
HERSCHEL WALKER WITH.
I WILL BE THERE TODAY HELPING
HIM.
>> I THINK THE POINT -- RICK
SCOTT IS EXACTLY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
IT IS EASY TO SIT HERE AND SAY
THE GEORGIA RACE DOES NOT MATTER
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT DETERMINE
THE SENATE LEADERSHIP ANTE IS
CORRECT, BUT IT IS STILL A VERY
IMPORTANT RACE.
ESPECIALLY GOING FORWARD.
THAT ONE VOTE WILL MATTER AFTER
TWO YEARS AND FOUR YEARS, I
SUSPECT.
MITCH MCCONNELL HAS A REAL
PROBLEM ON HIS HANDS RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE ALREADY STARTING TO SEE
PEOPLE TRYING TO CIRCLE THE
WAGONS AND THE SENATE TRYING TO
PROTECT HIM.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, MITCH
MCCONNELL HAS BEEN PART OF
LEADERSHIP FOR 20 YEARS.
HE HAS BEEN THE LEADER FOR 15
YEARS.
SO MANY OTHER PROBLEMS, WHETHER
IT IS ADDRESSING IN DIFFERENT
STATES, WHETHER WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT CANDIDATE SELECTION WHICH
HE WANTS TO DUMP OVER OR WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE MESSAGE THAT
REPUBLICANS CARRY FORWARD, I'M
SORRY, THAT FALLS TO HIS FEET.
IF YOUR COLLEGE FOOTBALL COACH
AND YOU COME UP WITH A LOSING
SEASON LIKE THIS, YOU WILL HAVE
TO PAY A HEAVY PRICE.
>> I'M NOT STANDING UP FOR MITCH
MCCONNELL, I'M JUST SAYING I
DON'T LIKE THE POSTURE OF SOME
OF THESE REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
KNIVES OUT SEIZING THESE
OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT IS NOT UNITY, THAT IS NOT
THE SAME PAGE.
JUST TO GO BACK TO GEORGIA, HOW
MUCH OF THE DEMOCRATS
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA THAT DID NOT
PASS OR GOT PASSED WITH A LOT OF
REPUBLICAN INPUT BECAUSE OF
SOMEONE LIKE JOE MANSION, HOW
MUCH IT THAT IS RUBBERSTAMPED
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
>> I JUST WANT TO PAUSE FOR A
SECOND AND READ YOU A TWEET FROM
SENATOR JOSH HOLLY.
TIME TO BURY IT, BUILD SOMETHING
NEW.
>> A LOT OF REPUBLICAN VOTERS
ARE FEELING THAT WAY.
THEN WE HAVE TO CONSIDER A WHOLE
NEW MESS THAT IS PROBABLY COMING
OUR WAY IF WE HAVE A TRUMP
ANNOUNCEMENT THIS WEEK.
IF WE THINK WE ARE DIVIDED NOW,
WAIT UNTIL DONALD TRUMP'S NAME
IS BACK IN THE RUNNING
OFFICIALLY.
I KNOW HE'S BEEN HINTING AT IT
FOR A LONG TIME, BUT WANTED SO
FACIALLY THEY ARE, NOT ONLY WILL
IT IMPACT GEORGIA, WHETHER THEY
LOVE HIM ENOUGH TO PUSH HIM OVER
THE LINE.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TWO YEARS TO SORT
OUT, WE BETTER START TODAY.
>> A GOOD FIGHT AND AN IMPORTANT
FIGHT.
MITCH MCCONNELL IS NOT ABLE TO
RUN A NATION